Every year, more and more young actors and
actresses make their mark on Hollywood, but
a rising Star can always be pushed aside by
an established Hollywood Legend.
Whether Oscar winning, Oscar nominated, or
just a fan favourite, every actor needs to
get their start somewhere - and even the greatest
thespians only have ONE first role.
Some are funny, some are fascinating, but
almost all of them are hard to believe.
Here are Screenrant's 10 Famous Actors' Movie
Debuts You've Never Seen.
Andrew Lincoln
Before this Walking Dead Star became famous
as officer Rick Grimes, he was busy making
movies in his native England.
Fans would have a hard time recognizing the
grizzled actor as the fresh-faced twenty-two
year old in Boston Kickout (OFG/First Look)
playing the troublemaking best friend of the
movie's hero.
Boys will be boys, but crashing into a store's
window for fun isn't something Rick would
approve of.
Bryan Cranston
In the 70s, no TV stars were more well-known
than the Six Million Dollar Man and the Bionic
Woman (ABC).
But when the two were reunited for a TV movie,
it was another actor who took the spotlight.
Twenty years before Breaking Bad made him
a household name, Bryan Cranston appeared
as "Dr. Sheppard," adding a high-profile credit
to an early list of small TV roles including
Airwolf, CHiPs and Hill Street Blues.
George Clooney
He may be seen as one of the sexiest men alive,
and an award winning actor and director, but
George Clooney came from humble beginnings.
His role in Return of the Killer Tomatoes
is memorable enough, but Clooney's first film
to hit theatres was another B-Movie:
Return to Horror High (New World Pictures).
It wasn't too hard to play an actor in a recreation
of a high school killing spree, but the future
superstar only received an off-screen death.
Tom Hanks
A role on the TV show Bosom Buddies was the
first big break for Tom Hanks, but his first
acting credit came in the slasher movie He
Knows You're Alone (United Artists/MGM).
Delivering a self-aware speech about society's
obsession with scary movies and rollercoaster
(1:01:53).
Since the movie was released not long after
the original Halloween became a hit, even
this brief insight into the horror movie genre
was years ahead of its time.
Brad Pitt
1987's No Man's Land (Orion Pictures) took
a thrilling look at the underworld of luxury
car theft in California, but it's just as
well-known for featuring Brad Pitt's in one
of his very first appearances in front of
a movie camera - even though audiences weren't
supposed to notice him.
When the films star's attend a swanky party,
the unmistakable star appears as a waiter
in two shots - unmistakable, thanks to the
incredible mullet that steals the scene.
Robert De Niro
Most movie fans would think that the Raging
Bull's first film role would be one to remember.
But in reality, it was never even meant to
be seen.
A single scene from the French film Three
Rooms in Manhattan takes place in a crowded
New York diner.
Viewers are meant to watch the two stars,
but it's hard to miss the now famous face
of De Niro in the background, playing a diner
patron in an uncredited role.
Al Pacino
These days, Al Pacino is known for playing
eccentric figures, in too many award-winning
roles to count.
But three years before starring as Michael
Corleone in The Godfather, Pacino made a small,
but just as memorable appearance in Me, Natalie
(National General Pictures, now Fox).
Playing a sleazy club patron who forces the
movie's star into a dance.
Who would have guessed his youngest role would
have so much in common with his older ones...?
Tom Cruise
The long blockbuster career of Tom Cruise
isn't filled with too many supporting roles,
since he gained the spotlight the second he
arrived in Hollywood.
But his very first role isn't one even fans
will remember.
In the tense teen romance Endless Love (Universal),
Cruise appears as Billy, the hero's friend
- and former attempted arsonist - who gives
him some truly bad advice.
Still, his short scene was all casting agents
needed to make him a megastar.
Tom Hardy
With roles in Christopher Nolan's blockbuster
Inception, as a Batman villain and even Mad
Max himself, Tom Hardy has taken Hollywood
by storm.
But audiences probably saw him in action before
they realized.
Hardy started his career by jumping into the
deep end, playing the hard-of-hearing Twombly,
a Delta Force soldier in Black Hawk Down (Columbia
Pictures).
He turned in a strong performance, but mass
audiences wouldn't be able to put his face
to a name for a few years - and a few dozens
of pounds - later.
Michael Fassbender
Today, there are just as many people who know
Michael Fassbender as the X-Men villain Magneto
as a serious, award winning dramatic actor.
But the Irish-German actor got his start working
with some of Hollywood's biggest talents in
the HBO series Band of Brothers.
These days Fassbender's face can sell movie
tickets all by itself.
But no war buff would have known at the time
that 'Sargent Pat Christenson' would become
even more well known than most of his castmates.
So what do you think of our list?
Have we missed some of your favorite first
appearances of famous actors or actresses?
Let us know in the comments, and be sure to
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one.